I am I am doing my
doctorate at the mendoza regional ute n
I am a systems engineer and I am
working on Internet
of Things and machine learning issues and
I also teach some subjects at the ute n
and one of them is
artificial intelligence in which  we use
a book it is not true of the famous ayma or
artificial intelligence for biting
prost yes
that book for sure all those who have
studied computer science have hurt us
from russel and norbit that at the moment they
have come across a chapter and in a
moment we need to update  the
untrue material from the class and take out
some we have other new ones and of
course talk about
reinforcement learning by informing learning in English
and that is where it came about and they assigned
this task to me yes and that is
where I learned to use learning
by  reinforcement and I discovered this open
jim shee framework where I come to present you
now at this moment
yes
in so in the first motivation with
the one that I found if discovering this
is like teaching a subject as complex as
reinforcement learning, it is not true in
a way where for students who
study electronic systems that, well, they
could rub elbows with this, see it in
a more dynamic way because I remember
when I  I studied it at one point it was
all formulas formulas it's not true and
well it's not the same it's true so I
want to start by reviewing a little what
you, if some of you have already studied it,
how many here already know what
supervised unsupervised machine learning is
good  half of the
audience great we are going to do a
review if of the two types of
learning in what is the area of
machine learning in the first place
be supervised that you have seen
many examples in other talks and
previous ones where you already
meet  a data set
labeled by some expert or person
who has labeled them data set
and in trouble
during data classification  images
among others that already there that good one
works is not true dividing your
data using part of that data to
train a model another part to
contrast that model how good it was
and they have seen a lot of it
these days
in general we can say  that in
machine learning we have
supervised and unsupervised and if I
compare it with what it would be, for example, if
I want to transfer this to clothing, it is not
true. I have a clothing data set.
I can say if I want to classify
good skirts, and this is a  skirt is not
a skirt I have a supervised problem
of classification in a
regression problem if I want to see the length of the
skirt it is not an image of the
average skirt how long it is and an unsupervised problem
from there we no longer have the
labels so  you have had a
clustering tutorial these days it
can be good for example to group the
skirts by their shape or by their color the
truth in that is let's say the big
c  Classification in very, very broad strokes
of what the
ma jin learn machine learning area would be, if,
as you can see, these two approaches
that require us to already have a
fairly large set of previous data is not
true
cases and others I cannot have this data
to
label unlike automatic
and informal learning erling where it is different in
the aspect of who we have an agent if
the definition tells us about an agent
this image is with a milestone robot because it
is quite applied in robotics in but
we can say that our program is  an
agent if some software is an agent
will require information from the environment if
the environment in which it is operating if
that environment would be in its environment and
also it is not only information but
also reward information or
rewards if it was going to interact with it
environment yes then something for other
types of problems yes where out there we don't
have all this amount of data
as it happens in robotics  a
and we have applied in our
lives and reinforcement learning as
people growing up right
since one observes it in children in
babies or how it was that we learned to
walk it is not true we did not learn from one
day to the next we did not come with a
function of how to learn but that it was
trial and error yes then in processes
where there is a lot of this that there are
many trial and error and I have feedback,
that is, we can say that it is
quite linked to this
reinforcement learning yes and that it is something that
we also observe like this  as we saw in our
childhood or in children it is not something
that happens from one day to the next it required
many iterations if we continue to
integrate day by day and we
interact with each other with
our environments and update
our information about the world the
environment that surrounds us  surrounds and well and
we give feedback yes like a
child we can say this don't stick your
fingers in the plug yes well it won't
be until o e  n one day you put them in the
account because it is not a ferry I keep
negative feedback we set that I am going to
receive and learn so as not to
do it again we are
formally certain reinforcement learning
is formulated as a framework decision model
or envipe and where we have a
agent that we are formulated a letter in
environment the states yes and people
will have perception of the environment of those
states if he was going to receive a
reward for performing some action
that we do it will take him from one state
to another it is not true then  for example
of these new robots it is not true that they
serve and that they clean the floor it is not
true that they re with their information about the
environment before from their sensors some
will have information that they receive back
in their cleaning sensors
so if they clean something dirty and  dirty
great you are raising more let's say
dirt from the floor in the case that not good
since it moves to another action if let's say
this is quite dynamic because the
environment can change  or also
over time
there are many applications today
of reinforcement learning in some
areas it is much stronger than others
as it is in the case of robotics because
for example in the case of this robot that
I gave you to clean you are going to
buy the robot and touch it cleans the floor and
the robot and tone have information about your
house it does not know how much you have how many
square meters your house has or the
map of your house nothing it does not have to
learn at the moment walking around the
house interacting with the environment
so in robotics it is quite used, let's say,
and for specific tasks,
let's say what they call it a goal or you
are or goal-oriented tasks
as in these cases that well in hyper strain they
mention many examples I
advise you to visit them that there is
a good robot for  example to push
boxes accommodate boxes others to
accommodate objects in some holes or
certain or it is in the case of
well-known control problems such as  or
stability the truth of the case of the
helicopter that flies is so
autonomous or it is being a humanoid robot that
has to be stable with certain
many problems also related
to controls are quite applied
in
it is also used in reinforcement learning
also of course in  what is
videogames it is true to be all this
simulated environment of videogames and
of course videogames have
their rules for rewarding scores there
is already an environment it is not true there are actions
and in there are even cases where
videogames these algorithms
reinforcement learning
video games already win and they play better than us
or any other person who is
super expert or super gamer playing it
is not true in these algorithms by
training a lot over time they have
come to really improve us
with many video game environments
in an application  very well known you
have also seen it in other talks it is the
alpha project  go is not true of google
of the google program who plays go
and was beaten by a go competitor and
other good things they have been creating many
versions of that algorithm and one of the
versions they made was good what
happens if we play no  it is true to the
phage against itself yes that is an
alpha go program of theirs against another in
favor that they are learning from them
then they started with an alpha
go program with an alpha go project where they
had no knowledge other than the
rules of the game  It is not true to
play with each other and they interact with an
environment and to see how it was being
perfected over time with
days of playing, it is not true you
can consult more about the project there in design
and well, after 21 days it reached
the alpha level  master, that is, twenty-one
days playing with all the
true combustion power of google and a lot
of other things
and reaching the same level as an alpha one
master and then, well, I
already surpassed them after 40 days  to be
training so they are quite
interesting another of the applications I
looked for many applications and one that
caught my attention is that it is being
used in chemistry to train admin and
the first thing that came to me is that image
I said what the chemists are doing  in
these that they are inventing and I found it
quite curious because well I have
a computer gift and there are
applications out there that are friendlier to
me and creativity really amazes me it
is not true where we can apply all
this good in chemistry it has many
processes for  create compounds that
require experimentation more true a
lot of trial and error things that mix
that sometimes are or are less true
so in this work what they
did is to do, say, use
reinforcement learning to speed
up this trial-error process, so to speak,
and well save  enough
money in what is instead of
mixing any
is true that tasks to perform for
improve its experimentation
and it is also being used a lot in terms of
recommendations and there is
relatively recent work on what it would be
to recommend news if when
someone is browsing a news web page
there are certain articles that one
reads others that one does not
interest others than not then how
do you recommend news then
in this case in this work they modeled
the problem as the environment were
the users and those news were grouped
grouped so to speak they created those
environments as if they were states the
newsgroups certain
newsgroups  of states, whether it be
entertainment, more gossip, more police, a
type of news and so on, and
accuracy was what the user gave about whether
he clicked, I read that news or not, the
truth of the river archives, obtaining you, and
I also found it quite interesting
because I know that good out there in everything
that the recommendation system
uses a
lot of other techniques  and well, we are
also beginning to see this because,
well, user feedback is something
that they can have immediately,
so we are beginning to
realize that many applications
ask us or not, in the end, this
advertising was useful to you, if it is not true, because it
we are helping it is not true to
label their data it is free in case you
did not know
but I also do not know if they will use it or not
for this and there are many applications
plus some incipient others there are
some not very related to the world of
computer science such as  the issue of, for example,
self-configuration of web systems,
so that's how to build an entire web platform
in the entire virtualization part,
everything is how much memory does it require, how many
users, a lot of things, there are
many parameters to configure,
well, there is a job that was put to  see
this as it could be automated with
reinforcement learning
but all this is difficult let's say that
a learning system  je for
reinforcements it is reproducible you
in science in general work with
problems one of the bits and
topix issues or hot topics or trending topics in
reproducibility problems it is not
true that it means that for example
just what you exposed miracle with all
your  algorithms and others and their data set I
can also replicate it for example in
other data do if one of the problems
that we know there is that does not happen
only in this environment of what
to reform it and I am talking to you in
general sciences the topic of
sharing  code data data sets and
you will know that today
in data science it is much
easier to replicate because it is
opening up a lot it is not true there is a
very strong movement of open day there is this way
of sharing data sharing code
exists that it does not  it's true we can compete
using street similar applications it
's true but I don't know if they had heard
of a charge to reform learning I don't know
and no  because there isn't, there is
competition, it's incipient, evil or
bad, it's called microsoft, which, well,
they offer an environment and everything to
start competing is, but it's something
incipient, so it's very difficult to
compare a certain if one publishes an
algorithm, e-learning reform  against another
environment because because I need the
same environment it is not true going back to
the
initial definition very quickly I need the same
environment the same environment yes to be
able to test it is not true the same
definitions to bring down the same states
yes then that is where the complexity comes in
It is not true, we need a
simulated environment so that we are not only
testing the algorithms,
that is where the open engine comes in, it
is a very nice project, it is an
opensource python library and it saved my life
to give very good classes, which is the
open
if it is about opera and  that it is a
non-profit second understood organization and
that it has shared many
open-source tools and that it is toolki  t provides you with
that provides you with various environments yes with
its agents with their states with their
safeguards with their rewards actions
already defined then it is fantastic
that we have studied the algorithms
or we can contrast algorithm one with
algorithms that are not certain or I can see how
it is  he made an environment in open there and there to
learn it is not true to create a
new environment of mine so for example
there are very similar problems like the one that
appears there in that little drawing that is the one about
balancing it is not true a stick on top
of a cart so  don't fall for it is
the one called
carpool that would be like hello world the
former learning to learn with that first
problem and it brings many environments if that
's what's also fun because it brings
environments to use like that what are called
in 2d graphics students in  2d also
other environments of more than robotics that
there uses some other external library of
erotica to simulate some
robotic arm that moves a way to give a
photo  rm and put it in its place yes
then we have several environments
to contrast against
and the classic control problems the
truth is good the pendulum everyone will have
seen at some point or in control or in
physics the pendulum the pendulum doubles and in
problems of speed or  how good the
cart goes up to the top
and of course the part of a very
fun part is that it is also linked to
an atari library yes to be able to
see all this and with some little games
well then what
an interface offers us a library a  toolkit yes
it is free you can use it to
apply these algorithms and we observe
here that well what we had talked about
before simply imports the library
one defines an environment an environment in
which it is not that it already has the open
eae library and one can expect a  true and for
each time the environment executes an action
if I choose an action in this case it is
executing a random action of those
that I could take in which people if
a  agent in what would be to inform you
the worst agent performs the client
performs randomly which means
that he takes any action at random
by the way he is not informed well this he
does as an example so that you can
see that when an action is executed
to this line
that an action was executed returns
information about the guard river of having
executed that action in that environment
and the observation of the state is not true
and of course then we can
visualize it as you see from time
well I wanted to show
something
well there is some code  notebooks I
don't know if it's going to look good but this is something
there I'm going to win because
I don't have the bolillos to
enlarge them I don't know I don't think they'll be able
to see it well those in the
back look good there's nothing there there isn't that
tall guy there  poison
well I don't want to go into a lot
of code details I just want
you to see how simple it is to download an
environment yes and get excited and
want to start doing c  With this,
if the links are on the overhead, so
you can calmly play
modify it later,
and
in this case, this is an example that
can help you because it brings a lot of
visualization of these environments, it is not
true, and to show these environments,
one needs to have some interface.  of
video and others
in this case to use it in google queue it
brings a whole tutorial on how to
show video on a certain browser
in google queue and in this case it is
running a pacman if we can load
the environment from pacman
observe these steps that I  I was telling them to
have an action or execute an
action randomly
that action if it takes it in the step and what
it does is something random then
we can be seeing what pacman
is doing and understand what
it would be like to execute something random
Notice that the pacman is not doing
as he is very informed, let's say, but what he
is doing if he does not have much
information, so
well
then what  I would like
[Music] to
show another environment
if you have a little patience with me
you can access through these
links that I am putting the slides and
play a little so as not to extend myself
too much in the presentation I will go through it
a little faster but I want you to
you see that you can interact with
this and have a way out if what
the algorithm is doing is
learning one of the
toy problems or the first thing that one would be
good to start when they do these
things in reinforcement learning are
by worlds type  grid yes or what they
call them I'm exactly that examples of
toys that are simple small examples
so this is an example of
one that the whole world is full of
ice there are 16 states with threads and these
there are little holes in the ice and our
people have  that learning to move
to reach a state of a beginning an
end it is true
that this is the front salt lake yes
atmosphere frozen law of
day in the open gym is loaded and  this
environment is good that of putting a
seed so that their experiments are to
reproduce them if they are not going to compare what
it does is a search in that of the
partner and they are going to see that they
are not going to care about this it represents
it here  this environment yes and in one you can
see in this case this environment has
information on all the transitions
the probabilities of transition of
people from one cell to another if you
mean that it models the entire transition from
one state to another according to the action
taken by the  environment if this is a
smaller environment so that can be done
then packaged algorithms can be applied
let's say in
reinforcement learning models because I have
this information
what you are seeing here is a table if
from the extra environment of the probability table p
and with the same
probability it can be moved to any
of the following cells that are
indexed from 0 to 15
this is good to know that is good there are
problems that you  You can work
wherever you are, you have this
state transition information and you can apply
these algorithms,
what is interesting here is that further down
we can see, for example, in this case
of a random agent, show the
rewards, what it is doing, yes, it is
very, very  the reward goes down evaluating
the behavior over time
there is an algorithm it is well known not to
go into details of these but not the
problem but basically what
that p is is my transition it is not true
if I have that information from that environment
that is  fully modeled those
transition probabilities I am going to use
this value iteration algorithm and
these are the rewards and the objective
is to maximize the utility of passing from one
state to the other yes
well and this is what it would be in Spanish in
the reading book and what  They will have seen
in classes and that the translation calls
them instead of values, let's say utilities,
the utilities table clarified it if
that happens when they translate the  technician in
English what are we going to do
good
the same thing that appears in the annotation is
here in python and the interesting thing is that
one can obtain information about
the policy from the people that the policy
is by default let's say the action that already
gave a state that  action choose the
people then for each state that
would be each one of the cells of this
small frozen world in this case
choose the zero action in this the 3 the 3
this is something important that I want to
clarify that it does not mean that the people
always that  execute the action zero
sorry decide to execute the action 0 to 0
it has been executed because because
we are in non-deterministic environments if
I can say I executed today in the
morning come here to the baida it is and it may
be that something happens in the middle
I hit a problem and well I don't come to
qaeda it's true then the
interesting thing about this is that one can
modify values ​​and others and here what we
observe is after executing several
iterations how it looks  this table of
utility or values
and we observe that there is a higher utility look
at the cells where
the gaps were not if then I want
you to keep that impression that
the algorithms are guiding us
towards the reinforcement learning algorithm
towards the path  like in
quotes correct or so that it doesn't fall
let's say into the gaps well
and then there are others that you can see
from the taxi without
and there is another algorithm that is the most
used when you don't have this
information
about environments that is cv learning was
one of the first and today in
modifications of this algorithm that is
based on maintaining a table q of
action state if you imagine that there is
a small table it is not true at the moment
of your head imagine that it is
dimensional that we have these two
actions  and that we want to maximize
let's say the value that returns us which is
the probability of transition between those
states if q learning works in that
way an acc is chosen  ion is executed
we get a reward and
the value of the table is updated q well
because you mentioned that because today you are going to
see words like inform learning or
kvitko learning or deep ahead of
reforming learning and one says that this is
true well
this table sorry
in  this talitá kum and in many problems it
can be much more complex
now I showed some simple examples
but in problems that require, for
example, computer vision it is not
true we mentioned that people are going to
think about their environment and if that environment, for
example, is through images and  status
can be an image the truth and then
the action it executed may or may not be an
image it may be to activate or deactivate
something the action may be simpler
then in those cases
a function has been included between formed
learning networks and blair link for  say on the one
hand what would be the input that
people are receiving their sensors
of course we know that they are used a lot
in vision in images and  n divx learning will
use and from learning
but there is another approach yes, that is when
this table is very large and from
states of actions there are already many
states of my problems or the actions to
execute and it is applied let's say deep
learning or a deep neural network
let's say  calculate or estimate the value of
this table without obtaining this I am interested in
knowing given a state an action what is
the most optimal maximum value to choose
the action then execute yes then that
is where you are getting into that is something from
a few years ago there is still a lot
research on the subject but it is
quite strong
you want to apply the reports to the
mine your project came here
that is why I tell you that it is very difficult that it is something
very challenging and that first you really
think about whether it is going to require
transforming it with any other technique much
more  simple it can be solved but if
your problem is very similar to something that
requires trial and error that allows
delays yes
or if you are willing  or to assume the
risks
working in we advise you to work in
simulated environments not to wait for this if this
were to come to us if we run those old ones
then the important thing is that you
first have a simulated environment or
if you don't have it you have
enough data to be able to build them
yes because  it requires many iterations if
we don't build a car and say
this car to be made autonomous we make it
run like this on the street from iteration 0
until I don't know how long and it's not a disaster
simulations are used in these environments
and of course the most important thing  it is to
understand the problem that you are
facing in order to define a stake,
a framework, decision process, be the
states that are going to have what that
change of states would be like if the actions that you
reward, how are you going to model the
rewards that are the most difficult to
face because the  algorithms exist,
libraries exist, so
let's say that is your task, you are the
experts with whom
there are many  many resources to learn this
from scratch if I particularly put
there those that I consider quite useful if
someone wants to learn from scratch and
there is this library, it
does look very nice for what it would be
when one wants to experiment try
many reformer
learning algorithms and I  it seems an
interesting example that I found this one with
arduino so that they can give me from someone
who did a bit of
reinforcement learning in a little while it's also good to
see that for those who like to get their hands on it
and this is a notebook for those who
want to continue getting into  hand
from cv learning from scratch so that things go
well thank you very much
bye given for the invitation I accept the
questions and please as this is my
first time of prayer and the first time
I speak about open
since the learning report I need
feedback to improve  in the next one
thank you
[Applause]
thank you for the question if you used the
attempt
I have to run it online on
some platform that I can hardly  do run it
was run it locally my offline machine
you can't if you install everything post
run it on your local machine in this
case to set up the class what
happened to me was that not all students
have the same capacity in their
computers yes then there is  many who
are with very limited netbooks and out
there it's good to use the internet in this
that's why I chose google queue for this but
nothing else but if you have everything installed
one of the problems thanks
hello thanks for the talk
my question was once I'm going to have
the whole environment is being created as
having a model as you train it because it
brings you today's idea the record is
that it is moderately in real time
while the model is running
investigating at the time the only thing
I found was was a network
neural and you had to do with an input
history bump apply your
word function and do a
bump training almost in real time while it
was running I
guess  or that this applies to a
neural network but perhaps for another type of
model there are other alternatives I do not know if
in general it is always
so that this would not be the case assuming
that it has been used as a reform in learning
I doubt very much that someone has put their
hand  that is, there is a whole part also
when it is a way of reading or passing
training of several iterations and
when those values ​​of the neural network or
for your table q or according to what you
are using more or less converge,
you evaluate the iterations yes how it goes
that accumulated reward is not true
how it behaves over time in
there you can say I release it to production
and it will respond quickly because
you only have those values ​​let's say if
it would not take a long time sitem and taking
into account that for example google in the
case of  alfa go was running for 21 days,
right, so there is also that
phase of training before leaving it in
production
and